[Music]
hey guys welcome back to another
installment of our sweet sound tutorial
videos that we're doing in conjunction
with the Dolby Institute so sit back
relax they'll learn some cool tricks of
how to make the foley in your videos
sound better than ever so you're on set
you have your mic and your focus on
recording the lines of your actor like
any good mic operator but what about the
other sounds the sound of their clothes
what they're interacting with their
footsteps well it's not really practical
to have 12 mics on set capturing all of
this but that's the kind of detail that
really brings the scene to life so
that's where Foley comes in so it is
fully Foley is simply the recreation of
everyday sounds in film and video that
aren't usually captured by your
microphone so too mundane but good
examples are footsteps and clothes
shuffling but Foley's isn't really just
the boring stuff take an action scene
for example handling of weapons and gear
the rustling of combat are all usually
added in this Foley process most
professional audio engineers record
Foley from large high-tech sound stages
and studios around the world filled with
sand boxes and random items that they
can quickly draw sounds from but doesn't
mean that you can't do it at home just
as easily so when we're recording Foley
this is our checklist first set up a
reference video to watch at the same
time we use Adobe Audition for this
well it times up if we're doing gear for
a fight scene it makes it a lot easier
to match the audio with the video you
also want to use the same microphone you
used on set if possible it makes the
audio matchup that much easier
exactly and last but not least make sure
it's quiet fans windows dogs everything
out
and trying to get reverb in your
recordings that really sells that you're
in a room rather than the space where
you film this shot yeah unless you're
actually in the room when you film the
shot unless you're actually yeah then
ask yourself what am I trying to
recreate huh let's say we have a
character running around for the ten of
swords and a cool jacket so those
stories aren't really plastic props and
they kind of sound like it also yeah
cool not to mention the boom operator is
most likely recording the character's
voice so the mic is even aimed at the
weapon what so for our scene we'd sit
down with a couple of dull metal weapons
or some aluminum swords and said because
we got these hat and record similar
motions with them or heck you know get
kitchen knives whatever something that
works and for kicks we've grabbed our
cool jacket too and get some great
sounds whipping it around so that it
sounds good with each swing Foley sounds
for the jacket ready cool hold the sword
fully sounds yeah we're doing fully try
not to uh yeah yeah don't do that
sometimes when recording a TR - that
happens like someone says it liner like
I only scream super loud and I start
like laughing and I hear like laughing
in the background
I don't but above all don't be afraid to
think outside the box here for sound
sometimes sounds onset or the actual
sounds objects make don't sound very
good and you will need to kind of use
some abstraction there to find something
that works case in point
all the sprinkles commercials are like
they're snapping into those chips yeah
that's egg shells being crunched really
oh just thinking about what
cool examples from our videos include
Blood Dragon where our sound designer
used this distorted low bass guitar for
all the futuristic sort effects
[Music]
and also sometimes we find that using
snow-packed like crunching sounds and
walking through that sounds way better
than actually walking through dirt you
have a character water dirt get creative
one thing that people get very confused
about with Foley is they're like oh so
like mean sound effects put sound
effects in your piece to make it better
well that's why Foley is different it's
not like a singular sound effect that
you're putting into your piece usually
these objects people are interacting
with in these movements
span entire scenes and sequences rather
than going and making that one sound
effect file and like placing it and
every single spot where an action like
that happened it's way quicker and
easier just to watch a scene just make
all the movements as you see them happen
on camera basically timing everything up
he basically can do the entire scene in
one pass rather than having to finagle
like a thousand different little Clips
exactly when watching a piece you'd be
very surprised at how much stuff is
added in later even though it sounds
like oh the guys opening a door like no
that's that's well that's a door sound
effect or like a guys rustling through
files and paper on his desk was like
there's no way they're actually
capturing all that audio onset you have
to go to your studio and record it all
there duh
Hey stop stop stop come on I mean the
big thing is fully unless you make your
movie hyper real it makes you hyper
aware of everything that's going on and
it helps to elevate that like magic of
cinema exactly because you know audio
cues are very powerful as we're saying
and when you bring attention to these
objects that normally seem mundane are
simple people pay more attention to it
you know they focus on like what's
what's the point why why is this
important and basically it just keeps
the audience more engaged with your
scene I hope you guys learn something
about fully hear and audio design in
general I know I certainly did Wow
we're doing a lot more audio videos so
if you like this stay subscribed and we
have a bunch more cool topics such as
audio mixing and a mystery topic coming
up soon
[Music]